(upbeat music)
Incoming bonus content.
Hi, I'm Rachel Dratch.
And I'm Ana Gasteyer.
And we're gonna take
the best friend test.
(Ana laughing)
This is a gimme.
Therapist.
Can we write two?
Okay.
At least we know both.
Okay, ready, set, go.
Oh, we got it!
We got it.
Oh my God!
I love that.
Best friends.
And look, we have to flip 'em.
Okay, ready, set, go.
Oh!
Oh, that was my other thought.
I bet.
I did 'cause then we...
Okay.
I was gonna say violin.
No, but you were
right about that.
That is because-
Violin was one thing that I did think of first,
and then this is like, well, you wouldn't know.
She's a very good cook.
You wouldn't know.
That's actually a better answer
because I do this sometimes.
That's exactly what I thought.
Okay, anyway, in my mind we're still three for three.
Okay.
That's what best friends do.
This is a terrible answer.
(both laughing)
This is a good one.
Okay. Ready?
One, two, three.
What is this?
Lentils.
(both laughing)
This pretty much sums her up in two words.
This is the opposite extremes of-
Of my passions.
(both laughing)
And that was a little bit extra for you.
(upbeat bright music)